I'm gonna give you Mark Cuban rule
number one and whenever you forget this
rule you're already out of business most
people do a lot of talking and most
people don't put in the effort there's
nothing you can't accomplish in life
with the right amount of work
everybody's got passion for something
Yeah right don't follow your passions
follow your efforts
what's that believe nation at seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want to see
you find it embrace it and make a
difference with it I started the mentor
me series to try to hang around people
who've done a lot more than us and
hopefully by spending a little more time
with them some of their beliefs their
mindsets their way of thinking seeps
into us to help us become the best
version of ourselves so today we're
gonna learn from one of the best Mark
Cuban and how to win in business and get
rich mentor me mark
[Music]
alright let's kick it off with rule
number one learn how to sell I'm gonna
give you Mark Cuban rule number one and
whenever you forget this rule you're
already out of business in every
business sales cures all has anybody
ever heard of a business that had zero
sales sales that was successful doesn't
happen yet a lot of people start their
business thinking I have a great idea
I'm gonna do this this is amazing
I'm gonna go raise money I just sold
this idea and then it comes back and
it's like okay you gotta sell that
product or you got to sell that service
that's the first and main key to a
successful business when you're getting
ready to start you have to answer that
question
rule number two do not be outworked
you know we all have ideas and we all
have business concepts when we think
okay this is a great idea and we all go
through that same process you know you
have the idea yeah you get excited about
it you get that feeling in your stomach
right then you go tell all your friends
and they say oh it's a great idea then
you go to Google and you look it up
right and you get all excited because
all that's not really anything like it
and you convince yourself but then the
key part is what happens next
and so I've always been of the attitude
that I want to be prepared I'm not a
risk taker
despite what people think and I avoid I
avoid risks by trying to know more about
what I'm trying to do than anybody like
I literally back when I was 15 16 I was
collecting stamps and that was another
one of my businesses and and I would go
and go to stamp shows in Pittsburgh and
I would take advantage of the variances
impressing from one stamp dealer to her
next so I'd say this you know I buy this
literally I went in one day with a
quarter buy something for a quarter and
turned that into $50 right by because I
put in the work to understand the stamp
market what stamps what they were priced
at and I tried to approach all my
businesses the same way whether it's the
Mavericks or being 12 or being 16 you're
always going to compete 99.9999% of
times you're gonna be competing with
somebody yeah somebody's going to want
to
do the same thing as you or try to do it
better what is it that you can do to be
prepared so that you know your industry
you know your business better than
anybody because if somebody else does it
better than you that means they're out
working you and the one thing you know I
talked about you know pouring the water
I also talked about the one thing in
life you can control is your effort yeah
right you can learn more about something
than anybody else yeah so the question
was are you born creative are you born
an entrepreneur or you know can you
figure that out yourself and the reality
is you can figure it out yourself you
know most people do a lot of talking and
most people don't put in the effort
there's nothing you can't accomplish in
life with the right amount of work the
challenge is you know are you willing to
do the work and the reality is most
people aren't but that's the opportunity
right is I mean it's like people you
know at school most people are lazy
right they they just they barely get
through it and and so that creates
opportunity I tell my kids that a if
they want something they're gonna have
to earn it
yeah and B if they don't work hard
enough to earn it I'm gonna sell them
off as medical experiments that's the
line in our house you need money okay
we'll set you off as a medical
experiment we can get you money that way
we'll give blood dad I'm seven I don't
care rule number three don't follow your
passion when you find something you're
good at yeah go for it
and I also also always say it's not
about passion everybody's got passion
for something yeah right don't follow
your passions follow your efforts
because people say you know I was
passionate to play baseball I was
passionate to play basketball doesn't
mean out all the sudden I was going to
be good enough yeah but I found myself
spending being really curious about
business being really curious about
technology and that curiosity is really
what drove me and I think particular if
you're young today curiosity is great
always learning and trying to find new
things and being curious about new
things because that's what leads you to
that path trying to figure out in
advance yeah that's hard because you
don't know what you don't know
was never really into technology when I
was a kid but then as I got a job that
used it I found out I was good at it and
once I found out I was good at it
then it became a lot more fun yeah you
know when you're good at something it's
almost always fun yeah and once it was
fun and I combined that with you know my
business skills then I saw okay I know
how to make money at this stuff because
I know how to sell now I know tech that
gives me something I love to do and so
you know what I tell people the key is
find something you love to do and be
great at it yeah because once you do
that it's all gravy rule number four put
your customers in a position to succeed
you have to execute everybody's got
ideas you know that's that's the easy
part
but customer what sale customer customer
happy yes or no sale customer customer
happy yes or no right sale because
everything just feeds that right
everything else is noise and if you and
part of that though so there is a part B
to that right because one tenant of good
business is always listen to your
customers right you always want to
listen but you don't always want to do
what they tell you right because a
customer's job is to just is to make
their company successful right and when
they tell you what they need and what
they tell you what they want they're
typically thinking about the right here
and now they're not thinking about your
potential competitors they're not take
thinking about the future of your
organization so you have to also
innovate you have to differentiate so
you have to have be over out here
innovating differentiating understanding
you know how you fit within your
industry and how you can get ahead but
then you have to turn that into sales
customers customer happiness and so if
you can execute on those things things
typically work out well it's not what my
office is pretty my office always looks
like crap right I mean our offices now
we we have these very desks everywhere
I'm not it you know you don't have to
look the part I mean I certainly never
have
right you don't have to sound the part
you just have to find a way to put your
customers in a position to succeed and
good things happen annual number five
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is try out different things you
just have to try different things and
even even if 99% of them fail you only
have to be right one time you don't have
to figure it all out in advance you can
be wrong you could pick the wrong career
you can pick the wrong job you can pick
the wrong spouse you can pick the wrong
whatever but you get it right one time
you're set but if you don't try and if
you don't go out there and try all those
different things you'll never get that
one time and so it's not a question of
okay how much stuff is different stuff
do I do or how many different things
should you try try them all try them all
until you find the one you like and then
it's like it gets really easy cuz even
when it's up you're on a mission you're
loving what you do you know and then
then it gets easy and so that's just the
approach I've always tried to instill in
people who work for me and myself
now I've got a very special Mark Cuban
bonus clip on how to ignore the opinion
of other people that I think you're
really gonna enjoy but before that I
want to know commitment of the day you
just watch this video what are you going
to make a commitment to changing in your
life or in your business write it down
in the comments when you write it down
it's much more likely to actually happen
so make that commitment let's see what
you got thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
most people really are concerned about
what people think about them it holds
them back you never ever ever ever have
it's not a part of who you are is that
your DNA or where did that come from I
don't know I just never gave a yeah it's
just once you get success in something I
mean even when look I failed many times
and you learn from those failures that
it doesn't hurt as bad as you thought
you know that you can bounce back and
then once you taste some success you
realize it doesn't matter how many times
you failed right you only have to be one
right one time then everyone's always an
overnight success or you know this came
easy to them you know you just you just
got to keep on grinding and and keep on
trying new things and you know once you
start feeling the success you realize
look it doesn't matter what the other
people think other than my customers
other than my you know my partners other
than my employees I care what they think
but you know from the outside looking in
I was always just so focused that I just
never I mean I got distracted from time
I don't want to say never distracted but
you know I just didn't want anybody else
I don't want to think that how people
saw me was a reflection of the job I was
doing you know if my customers were
happy if the stakeholders were happy I
was happy raise your standard Apple at
the core its core value is that that
people passion not one drop of most
self-worth depends on Europe that's
supposed to mean I don't ever give up
I'd have to be
dead or completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten rows of
success I have a very special secret
video for you these are the individual
clips that I have personally learned the
most from and applied to my life and my
business check the link in description
for details